you know that girl who was hardcore
party girl
born again virgins yeah
then they become spiritual they become
spiritual into healing and and all that
stuff and they kind of leave oh my gosh
at once once i saw
the rolos book when he talks about how
girls find god around like 26 to 30
right right when like time's running out
to find a husband i like could not unsee
it i was like ruined church for me
forever even with the church thing i
think the most geekiest
guys ugliest guys get the hottest girls
in church because they show how
spiritual they are so i think the same
way women are running out of age because
they're going to have a man i'm just
like you know you're going because of
god
but here's my question
here's the thing it's a mating strategy
it's basically like like what i've seen
is it's typically girls that have been
like ran through so they're trying to
they're trying to up their values so
they're saying okay i'm spiritual now i
found god whatever so they're they're
basically saying okay you have to pay a
higher price
even though the valley even even the
value this happens all the time this is
like chest like i did i did catholic
school 12 years we had a chastity
speaker come in and she re-waited till
she was married even though she slept
with all these guys in high school and
they're marketing this yeah like this is
this is a bad deal for men are you
saying that sounds good and so so it's a
mating strategy so the man it's like it
fulfills his mating strategy because he
he's usually like a less like more of a
beta like kind of a simp because there's
so many simpson churches and so
like it fulfills his mating strategy
because he usually gets a girl that's
kind of out of his league but she's like
ran through so it's like
so it's like she might be attractive but
she's got like maybe a couple of kids
and yeah like she's been run through the
guys kind of because i've actually heard
church women say that the men in church
are either all taken
or they're all the types of guys that
they don't really want to be with and
then generally what tends to happen is
women in the church because the church
is majority women as we already know
yeah um the women want to find a man
they do find a man they find him outside
of the church and they bring him in and
they bring him in and then the pastor
says you're not equally yolked and you
can't be with that guy yeah but she's
dumb because obviously you know at the
beginning what equally yoke means so you
should be going for someone yeah but the
thing is women yeah but women want a
partner they're not attracted to those
and most of the men are interested
because clearly he's not going to work
so why are you going to go for someone
because there's not there's not enough
men in the churches like and it's
usually three three women for one dude
but i'm saying if if it comes down to
the point of you know eagle yolks and
what have you
that woman really there's no point there
for something it's not gonna work in it
unfortunately i think it can work i
think the church as i've said before i
think the church keeps women single
i think the church keeps women
perpetually you're right about that
right yeah i think that you know from
the pastor to the teachings to the way
in which they're expected to deal with
men i think it keeps women
and they take all they take all
accountability off of women churches do
it too and it's even i remember in high
school listening to this chastity
speaker because she comes in and like
it's always oh i was so broken blah blah
blah shut up you were horny like why are
you like shut up
and so she'll come in and say i was so
broken i made all these decisions i just
felt so bad about myself not
really i mean kind of taking
accountability but not not really you
know
and
then um all i had to do was say sorry
and i had a husband waiting for me at
the end and that's just not it's almost
like it's almost like a christian
another twist on the cardi b record i
can be a hoe how where where is purity
culture in
it's in christianity yeah yeah but
there's a difference between like the
bible and like
christian culture so that just that's
just something that is invented for
today like it hasn't always existed
right
like the whole purity culture that like
the bible teaches to be pure
like for god not so you can get a man or
so you can get in women but in today's
society obviously some churches want to
attract more attendants and so they
promise these women who have been run
through as you say
that oh if you just keep yourself pure
you're going to get a man but that's
nowhere found in the scriptures
so that's just a message that's tailored
to the modern women today yeah but i'm
saying it's found in churches like so
you're trying to yeah you're trying to
take it off at churches but churches are
the one doing it no i'm not talking
about that church is i'm taking it off
the bible like christianity because i'm
not i'm not hating i'm not hating on
christianity like yeah i'm just i'm just
saying like i grew up i grew up catholic
like i'm right i go to christian church
right but
i'm just saying it's a problem do you
think it's a good strategy though
like for a woman to have been run
through to go to church quote unquote
ran through to go to church to find a
new man what do you mean what do you
think is a good do you think it's a good
mating strategy for women
like do you think they'll go do you
think the majority of women who find god
and after they've you know been holes
essentially right do you think that it's
a good mating strategy for them to go to
church to find a man
there's there's only gonna be hoes in
church but everyone in church
but no the church wow what okay so
they're sinners yeah
my thing is the church is for sinners
and for those and for the all those
people being all that stuff so
all and then you've come to the lord and
to become new to become perfect so i
don't understand i mean you're looking
for a virgin mary in church you've got
to be quite shocked
but my experience of that
that's afraid enough statement i'm not
gonna lie
i hear that my experience at church is
that they don't really they don't really
preach much to do with
the importance of family and stuff like
that a lot of it's to do with
church well i've been to i've been to a
few churches i don't generally go to
church right but i've generally been to
churches all throughout my my life you
know i mean but i don't i don't see much
uh
preaching about
the importance of
a a man and a woman and the family and
and and sticking in that situation and
so on and so forth so what what do they
i miss i miss the days a lot of it's a
lot of what i hear is to do with um
um
which is which is what it should be if
you if you know love god a lot of us do
is
prosperity do you know what i mean
a lot of it's gonna do with prosperity
in itself okay and i think that a lot of
that's to do with
just collecting
church a lot of that's to do with just
keeping people in church because at the
end of the day if you um the collection
plate comes around all the time so i
think if you keep people in church
you're going to make sure that you know
the the church business runs that's hope
dealing in order like but i think that's
what a lot of it is and that's why you
don't see men in church that's why you
don't see many churches at the end of
the day men
believe it or not actually want family
yeah they actually want uh i said this
before i said this before men and women
view god differently
right
women are attracted to powerful male
figures that's what they're attracted to
the ultimate powerful male figure is who
when a child
yeah right which is why you hear women
say i don't need no man i got jesus
you never hear a man say i don't need no
woman i got jesus because it's gay i've
never heard
so it's like women and women and men see
god differently which is why
you know what that's what that's why you
find the majority of women in church
because they're going to see their
ultimate man can i just correct you paul
did say it in the bible if you read it
i'm saying yeah but i'm saying generally
you don't you don't hear men in the
society saying
i don't need a woman
but those those women are on deceiving
themselves because we all need each
other so it doesn't i don't know why
they're saying that they're probably
hurt no but i'm saying
the pastor should tell them to put
themselves on discount you know what i
mean
but that would be against the bible so
he's going to give a counselor
i'm just saying it's also against that
it's also it's also against the bible to
be run through and have kids outside of
marriage
it's like but i'm saying this is what
girls do is they'll they'll do these
things and then come to church and try
to raise their value and i'm saying it's
a mating strategy i knew a girl his mom
did that she had like three kids by
three different dads
and then became born again christian it
was all like yeah but you're supposed to
that's the whole point the whole point
of asking men to wait till i miss the
days i miss the days i miss the days
when we would deny people from churches
like no no rebecca no rebecca you've
been ran through by the whole football
team no you can't come but that's not
like no you're not that's the opposite
of the bible
look at it look at it
i i feel like people should be denied
from churches when you can tell they're
clearly not sorry and they're clearly
not living the word i'm sorry
i'm somewhere in between i think okay
how are we going to this church
no i'm like cool go to church do your
thing get right with god whatever you've
got to do
but then they become holier than that
and they start to preach that's people
for you like when someone that when when
a hoe gets married or when a girl gets
married she'll tell everyone all the way
she did it the way she did that's how
people are just like they have to choose
religion at that point to be holding
down but if you were that you were
single now you've got a man you want to
preach every single girl how to get a
man these times that girl don't want to
have a man so just become how people are
interesting and should it be the same
for the men because i personally know
someone who is a man who didn't want to
have sex before marriage obviously when
he became a christian
and he was trying to put his girl to
that standard as well which obviously
she couldn't meet so should it be to say
that oh because the man
why couldn't she meet that because she
wasn't a christian that she wants sex
okay yeah he didn't want sex so he was
in the church you're saying yeah she was
outside the church yeah
he wanted to get with him he should find
a virgin girl right or asexual like come
on man you can go here
i don't think that's very christian
but people don't have sex like literally
collect there's people there for
everyone just find your tribe find a
person that works for you like clearly
you now become christian she's mad
you're a person there's more women than
man you're banging every day and then
but i mean if men are then cheated so so
what so the men are cheating only
cheating on the same women then so if
it's how has it worked right but the
thing is think about that
that's why baby mothers are fighting
over
fighting with each other because the
same men are breeding the same women
yeah those top guys are breeding ask a
guy
if he's got more than one baby mother if
he's got a child he's probably got two
maybe three
so these women who know these guys are
like this keep choosing this guy to
breed with so then they start arguing
like they always argue
well you guys are saying women are
dum-dums you said it yeah i can't i can
say that because i mean we talk about
women women have both way fathers
like why would you be number five sis
why would would you number three because
they think it emotionally well thank you
because he's shown that he can provide
yeah it's it's a it's a it's it's a
biological it's about biologically it's
it's a attraction cue
to know to know that he's taking care of
different
baby mothers on top of that they can get
a check okay you're incentivized i think
a lot to do with the check but then to
be honest with you if i meet a guy who's
got five kids i'd be like wow what does
that thing do because you got five kids
but that's as far as it's gonna go
because come one i'm not gonna number
six but let's face it if you got six
well you're curious
oh come on i protect myself but come on
you've done enough like you must be
something good down there like you know
what i'm not it was fine of you as well
i can't lie i've i met a girl i know of
a girl that she is in her prime as a
female at a certain age as a woman yeah
as a woman right and she met a guy who's
in his 40s or going towards there and
she started finding out things as they
were dating about baby mama number one
then there's number two
and she's in it like
deep in it she's asked about questions
maybe not but more so than anything
when coming to her male friends about it
she she was told
we can tell this guy
has he's done life
that guy is unlike you know what i mean
and like she didn't want to listen she
was happy in it and then when she
started uncovering all these things
she's too far deep in it
women know yeah they don't get fbi
friends they're attracted to it